when the drugs are taken chronically
your brain becomes tolerant to them and
your brain actually probably changes
and then when you when the drug is taken
away then
people are suffering in many cases very
severe
withdrawal effects for long periods of
time so your
your experience is not uncommon
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode 83.
on this episode i'm joined by dr jim
wright and dr david cohen
to discuss the dangers of
pharmaceuticals this episode is
extremely important to me
because pharmaceuticals nearly killed my
dad and ruined my life
for years ssri withdrawal something i
didn't even know existed
gave me the worst psychiatric symptoms
i've ever had for more than two and a
half years after i stopped taking them
if i hadn't had the diet i'm on now i
don't know what i would have done
it was like i was in hell so i brought
two experts on to discuss
the dangers behind psychiatric
medications and pharmaceuticals and
dependency and withdrawal and suicide
this is an episode everyone should hear
if they or a loved one is on a
psychiatric medication or considering
one
i'm going to be putting out an episode
about my experience with medication at
some point but for now there's this one
dr jim wright is a clinical
pharmacologist he has a phd in
pharmacology from mcgill
he spent his career studying
prescription drugs dr david cohen
is an author professor and associate
dean for research and development at
luskin
school of social work ucla i highly
recommend checking out the new
documentary film
medicating normal which i have linked
below so please check that out
if you enjoy this content or at least
learn something please consider hitting
subscribe
this episode is brought to you by true
local trulocal.cas where i get my meat
from
use code mp for free steaks you may have
heard me talk
about this company multiple times for a
while now because i was using them
even before they sponsored my podcast
with truelocal you choose what goes in
your box and they send it to you
they have any meat you could possibly
want and even some organs
what true local does is they connect
with local farmers so you get to buy
farmed meat sustainable nutritious
it tastes great an added benefit is you
get an amazing product while at the same
time supporting local farmers
one of the things that really helped my
ssri withdrawal
was my all meat lion diet it literally
probably saved my life adding meat to
your diet is a super easy way to get
healthier
uh true locals great i recommend their
grain fed beef wild salmon their lamb is
some of the best lamb i've ever had
go to trulocal.ca and use codemp for
free stakes in your box
i hope you learned something from this
episode it's a really important one
dr jim wright and dr david cohen welcome
to my podcast
thank you thank you yeah
can we start off um dr wright could you
give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you've done with your life
sure um my i'm a pharmacologist
and i became interested in pharmacology
when i was in medicine
and so i've practiced medicine with an
interest in pharmacology from the very
beginning
i did my medical degree in
[Music]
edmonton the university of alberta
graduated in
1968 and then i went to montreal
and interned at the montreal general
hospital and there was a strong
clinical pharmacology program at the
montreal general hospital at that time
and so i became interested in that and
uh and then i interrupted my training in
internal medicine to do a phd
in pharmacology at mcgill and stayed
with the
clinical pharmacology people at uh at
the montreal general
during my uh phd training and so in the
end
i did a post-doc at hammersmith hospital
in london
and then came back as an assistant
professor at the university of british
columbia
as a clinical pharmacologist i had a
joint appointment in medicine and and
pharmacology
and therapeutics and all of my career
i've been studying
prescription drugs and so i have a very
strong understanding of drugs
and unfortunately most doctors don't get
much training in pharmacology and and
most psychiatrists have
very little really understanding in
pharmacology they
they they know the names of drugs but
they don't really understand the
complexity
of the drugs and and drugs are extremely
complex and we still don't know
nearly enough about drugs so that's
that's really my perspective
okay dr cohen over to you well
i hope with my life i've done good
things to
the people that uh depend on me and so
that's
my first statement but i um
as a professional i began my
career as a clinical social worker in
montreal canada
i now live in los angeles and i teach at
the university of california in los
angeles i'm a professor of social
welfare
as i began my career back in the 70s
i encountered a number of people who
were taking prescribed psychiatric drugs
and i quickly began to understand that
the drugs not only affected the way they
thought about themselves or felt about
themselves but the way
others looked at them and ever since
that time
through numerous uh scholarly
and research uh endeavors
in canada and france in the united
states
i um i pursued my study focusing
on prescription psychiatric drugs
psychoactive drugs
or psychotropic drugs different names we
get
the drugs that seem to cross that blood
brain barrier and affect how people
think feel behave and i focus mostly on
the prescription drugs and
how different groups of people
ordinary people professionals
physicians teachers social workers
psychologists judges
lawyers think about the drugs
and um how the drugs play
in their own thinking to
to shape how they see disability
and people's chances to recover from
disability
what ails people what makes people tick
the drugs have a central place over the
last 50 to 80 years
shaping how we speak about distress
generally so i've looked at the social
issues surrounding the drug use
i've carried out a number of
epidemiological studies
way back in the 80s i was among the
first researchers documenting the spread
of the use of ritalin in quebec
and um so in different countries i've
been looking at how different
cultures approach the use of drugs
especially with children
and how their knowledge is then sort of
sent back in that globalized world
to then influence how other countries
approach drug use and so forth so all
this to say that
i've not studied pharmacology
in the um in the manner that
dr wright has studied pharmacology
but i have complemented my study of
pharmacology
with the other parts of
drug action which have to do with
interpersonal
relations social relations commercial
relations
all these shape how drugs affect people
okay fantastic um i'm really glad you
guys came on
i've been wanting to talk to people who
worked on the film
mad in america for a while um i myself i
i was prescribed antidepressants when i
was 12. and i stopped taking them when i
was 23
when i i eliminated some factors from my
diet
my level of inflammation went down and
my depression went away
and i stopped taking them over a period
of two weeks and for two and a half
years i had really severe
withdrawal and at the time i wasn't
aware that
you couldn't just stop taking
antidepressants because i didn't know
that
they could be dependency forming so
i guess i'll i'll direct this to dr
right but
are there are what do you think the
major misconceptions about
uh psychiatric medications are currently
okay that's good the the major issue is
that psychiatric medications well
basically almost
all medications can get onto the market
with fairly short-term trials
so and that's true for antidepressants
and
antipsychotics and and benzodiazepines
etc they
they're studied in trials that are
primarily sort of six to eight weeks and
maybe sometimes
12 weeks and so the only evidence that
we have
for any of these drugs is is short-term
and then the problem is that people
don't get just treated
short-term they get treated long-term
and there are no long-term trials and we
actually don't know what the safety
of these drugs is uh long-term and
that's the huge
issue and so if if they only were
prescribed uh the way they've been
studied
um they you know we there wouldn't be
nearly as much of a problem
if they if you only got the drugs for
for a cup for um say
four to six weeks and then it was
stopped
probably much less problems would occur
but
when when the drugs are taken
chronically
um your your brain becomes tolerant to
them
and your brain actually probably changes
and then when you when the drug is taken
away then
people are suffering in many cases very
severe
withdrawal effects for long periods of
time so your
your experience is not uncommon and
that's what the
movie meditating normal is is really
showing
is showing these people who have been
severely damaged
by by these drugs in the long term
and i think if people really did
understand the drug and know how little
we know about
the long-term effects of these drugs
there would be very few people
who would be taking these drugs and
more i know about drugs the less likely
i am to take in
and i don't take any drugs at the
present time
um and i and i would have to be very
convinced uh
of long-term uh benefits of weighing the
harms before i would ever
take a drug on a long-term basis so
that's really
a big issue and the incentive to have
people taking long-term drugs is
a lot of it's coming from the
pharmaceutical industry
because that's where they make their
money is having people taking
drugs on a long-term basis so
so that's that's the biggest problem i
think right now
yeah i'd say that's a pretty big problem
um dr cohen over the years
what has the change been in i guess
prescription to young people or
how many people are on prescription
medications um
i guess since you started working
huge change over the years so i would
say if you
if we take the 40-year perspective 40
years ago
um there's been in north america at
least
canada united states not quite mexico
um uh quadrupling
or coupling five times more
psychotropic drug use um
now than than 40 years ago and
especially for children
so we're looking now united states
canada as about
one adult on in five or six
and one child in nine or ten
on a prescribed psychiatric drug
and i'm excluding here the the opiates
which are definitely uh prototypical
psychotropic drugs but they're often
just prescribed for
pain but if you include the opiates in
there
that probably adds another person in 10
to the overall europe it would be one
adult in
three closer to one in three but much
less much many fewer children definitely
under one in
20 whereas it's about one in nine or ten
in in north america again for kids
so i wanted to add also to
dr wright's really comprehensive
overview
is that the cautions that we might feel
as
ordinary citizens about long-term use
are short-circuited by the ideas
that many of us are deficient or uh
suffer from some sort of pre-existing
brain abnormality
that's kind of subtle and that requires
treatment with drugs so the way i see it
one of the
biggest misconceptions about the
psychiatric drugs
is that they are these medical
remedies that only act in a particular
way on this presumed disease
or abnormality or imbalance that we have
and that idea is a commercial idea in
other words it's a
sort of it it's a scientific hypothesis
but it's not supported and but it's
used as a kind of an archetype that is
very resilient to any change because
people believe oh so
that's why it works that's why my
doctor's offering it
that's why i recovered and they latch on
to it and it overwhelms our
kind of more cautious defenses about
using things over the long term
okay how did how did this happen because
i mean i would guess that you go back
maybe
100 years for sure but a certain amount
of time and these drugs didn't exist
and so this wasn't happening and then
slowly we were told that
these psychiatric illnesses like you
said i was told i was
i had an uh serotonin problem um
for some reason and that this would
treat it and i'd probably be on it for
the rest of my life and then
when i stopped it was catastrophic
so what exactly happened with the
medical system
to get doctors to so readily prescribe
these medications
um so if i can uh jump in here
um the you know this whole idea that uh
drugs will correct uh uh a problem or
is uh is very naive i mean the the
complexity of the brain
and uh of what uh of how we how we
function
it's so great that the idea that you
could actually put a chemical in there
and it would uh you know only would
correct a specific problem is is
extremely naive and uh
and and the whole serotonin hypothesis
has been disproven many times so that's
definitely not true and so there is no
uh chemical imbalance uh that these
drugs uh correct
but it that's it's a marketing um
um that has occurred really and and i
think it's
basically marketing uh but doctors have
bought into that marketing
and uh and and many would believe it i
guess and so then they uh
they follow along with that but it's
it's not true
and uh and there are no um
uh no psychiatric conditions that can be
corrected
by drugs there it's all symptomatic
um treatment and as i say there are no
long-term trials so we don't know
what the benefits uh um and harms are
over the long
term and and probably
the number of people who are being
harmed my guess is that the harms
outweigh the benefits for
most of the drugs that are given long
term for psychiatric illness
which is a really a huge
um statement but uh and
but it is something we really should be
uh looking at uh
so i i think there's great need for for
more research
to find out um about these drugs
and i i would also just uh bring it up
now is that
these people who are having long-term
severe harms and severe side effects
i think they need to be studied we need
to find out what is it
happening in the brains of these people
and i think if we had a
um i think it's possible that for at
least
maybe in the future but even now maybe
there is a way to measure
some of the changes that are occurring
and then that would help these people
to be able to say you know they what
what is occurring
and then also maybe help other people to
detect when they're when they're having
some damage
and to stop the drug sooner so it's a
it's a it's a big issue
i wondered if i could uh also complement
that with
uh by returning to the question you
asked me talia about
how or why did this happen how did this
happen
got to such a state where so many people
are being prescribed these drugs to
change their moods and behavior
and i wanted to to to say that we've
always
had and we still do have the whole world
can be divided into maps of you know
psychoactive drug use
so this is not a new phenomenon to have
a culture
drug cultures that spread over
continents we've had them i think since
the dawn of time since recorded history
it's just that over the last let's say
50 to 100 years
especially there's been this avalanche
of synthesized you know modern
psychotropics
that have been uh that have
corporate champions that are backing
them up
with billions of dollars of promotional
efforts
so that you know when you ally people's
desires
for drugs and that has been pretty
constant
throughout history as far as we can tell
when you ally that desire
with the corporate pharmaceutical
promotion
you know the tools of modern advertising
to
physicians and the public then you have
forces that almost no one can resist
so but how did it all happen i think
it's not a simple answer to that but
these are
many many trends converging from the
anticipation of
women to the uh medicalization and the
loss
of uh say religious influences to the
dissolution of a large extended families
to all kinds of social factors play into
the fact that we are now
feel responsible for um
for you know turning ourselves into
these
neurochemical sensors out there
that's all we are that's how you know
the promotion is that we are these
neurochemical units that require
adjustment by experts who know better
that that's the big change over 50 years
yeah i suppose it's not surprising um
that with
i mean north american lives just lives
in general are stressful
especially without the family unit or
extended family and
if you're offered something that's going
to take some of the
existential dread away theoretically
then it's no wonder that
you you jump on it if you think it's
safe because you're told that a lot of
these are perfectly safe
that they're not like at least at least
nowadays if you take some sort of
painkiller or an
opiate you're generally you generally
know that it's addictive that there's
going to be some sort of withdrawal
but i don't think the knowledge that
there's withdrawal with
psychotropic medications other than
maybe benzodiazepines but even there i
think that's
i think that's rather new uh i was in
russia last year with my dad because
he was trying to get off he was on a
number of medications that were
that were really treating his ssri
withdrawal
and he was he had academia from these
medications
and he couldn't get treatment in north
america because they kept adding on more
medications and when we got to russia
they did mris and they looked at his
brain and they said oh he has brain
changes
it's probably from the you know 15 years
of ssri use
and and i was there thinking you can see
brain changes from ssri use that cannot
be good
and it's not something i'd ever heard in
north america that
that there are changes you can see on
mris
based on psychotropic drug usage
but apparently in russia it was
something they'd seen
quite frequently especially from people
who'd come from the west to go over
there for treatment
so that was a bit concerning
so what what treatment did he did he get
um
so so um so generally with
benzodiazepines at least out here you're
told that you need to do a very very
slow taper
but his akathesia was so severe
that he couldn't tolerate a uh taper
so every time he went down it got worse
but
it was just completely unbearable where
he was at as well
and we brought him to russia because
they
they they offered a detox which is
something
that you're not supposed to do with
benzodiazepines but he was
like he was really close to
dead it was really bad and we did a
detox there
and he was eventually stabilized with
suboxone and low-dose mirtazapine
and that worked so
he he's he's almost off everything he's
doing
really well he's probably doing better
than he has in um
in years anyway um since the ssri
withdrawal and the benzodiazepines but
it was
suboxone and mertazapine and a
benzodiazepine
detox that ended up helping him which
isn't something that like
they offer here at all but it was really
not good
it was a very bad situation well i might
say that
as the rule when physicians in north
america are presented with difficult
withdrawal situations
the reflex would be to add on another
drug
a stabilizer start playing around with
well let's add on another drug usually a
kind of a
more sedative drug to mask over
and so you know it's not surprising that
other drugs would have been
added in the treatment you're describing
maybe what they did is they did
they did it quickly in a very sort of
protected environment sort of
and it could have been that way where
they just kind of went at it
systematically and only did that
until you know everyone agreed the
problem
is mostly over which here they might not
do they would just keep
throwing drugs and different drugs and
and might not
taper so quickly and so on and so forth
because the physicians are not so
educated
into how we de-prescribe so
that's an issue where different
countries might feel
they want to go at it in a more direct
manner so there's no accepted
uh protocol really for withdrawing
from almost any drug it's just
trial and error with lots of tradition
and learning by
example and so forth but the idea is
it takes time
that's really the solution it takes time
and the brain and the body and the
person and their beliefs
all have to readjust while
and that takes time for some people it
takes
less and for others it takes more
sometimes way more but we haven't
figured out
what is the recipe for everyone
and so that's where the social and
personal factors come in
in my experience working with people
trying to come off
i found that those who believe that they
have a chemical imbalance to begin with
those have a harder time coming off the
drugs
and it's just my observation i can't
generalize it
but it's an ingredient that seems to
play
so it's more than just the body
it's your state of dependence on other
people who believe you need the drugs
it's what you believe is wrong with you
or what's wrong with you to begin with
why you've got on the drugs
and many other idiosyncratic factors
that play into the difficulties
that one might have coming off
psychiatric drugs yeah so if i
i just yeah the people that i'm helping
to come off of drugs um
i i mean i agree with um uh with you
uh dr cohen uh the they you know they
need to believe
um and and and it's been proven uh
in many cases uh that that the only
thing that's going to heal them is to
get off everything
and so they often say well you know what
can i take to make this easier and
i i strongly advise them that there
isn't anything they can take to make it
easier
it just complicates things right so the
brain is is very complex if you put
another drug in there that's uh
doing other things to the brain it's
only going to make it
more difficult to
to get off and so they they need to be
highly motivated and they need to
come off at the rate that's best for
them and some of them it's faster and
some of them it's
slower but it the the all the long-term
goal has to be that they get off
completely and the ones who are
successful are the ones who
uh get off completely and many of them
experience like what you what you did
have a long term
withdrawal symptoms even after they're
off everything but they also have to
then be reassured that that will
gradually disappear and they can and
that the brain can heal from this
injury that has occurred just one other
thing this
mri findings i mean if those are real
then those need to be published and
uh you know and and and this and uh
disseminated to the world because that's
uh in my experience um we we haven't
been able to find any uh
any findings that are specific to to
this situation
yeah yeah okay so this was this was wild
we we went to
moscow and then we were in this really
old soviet
huge soviet hospital that had like
guards around it
it was completely absurd and we went in
there and
they were they didn't speak english
there's these all these russian doctors
that had been working there since the
soviet era
and it was a reanimatology clinic so for
brain
for seriously brain damaged people and
they had
you know and it was it was an excellent
hospital
i've never seen a hospital run that
smoothly
uh and yeah they pulled up an mri and
said yeah there's
there's brain damage from from
antidepressants
and i was just like how how
do you have that uh so
i don't know russians man i don't know
what they're up to but
i mean they they there are russian
scientists who publish uh so i mean
that's what that's it's it's important
right if they have something that's uh
um that the world needs to know then
they should be publishing it
and it can be duplicated elsewhere yeah
i'm sorry i i spoke uh over someone's
voice
i wanted to say that the principle of
measuring the state of the brain before
you start drug treatment
and then while you're on drugs
and then after you stop that's something
that should be done as a matter of uh
you know
as a routine we should do it for
uh for almost everyone
in in some way or other people require
some
baseline information before you're on
drugs
and and then after and at different
times we should do it for
electroshock or ect we should do it for
other things that are said to be
harmless
simply as a matter of course and to
build up databases where we can
really over several hundred people or
thousands
have a good idea what sort of changes
occur
because otherwise it's just different
claims being
made that oh this damages the brain this
is completely
safe we don't know so the evidence is
only
gathered systematically by agencies that
are not
interested really responsibly
in assessing what are the physical and
physiological damages
to all the bodily systems not just the
brain
to the organs to you know to the 30 or
50 physical systems that we harbor
we need to know over the long term what
does happen
especially what happens to people who
start young
before the adolescents who are taking
drugs from the age of
yeah 18 what happened to them
over the next 10 years after they even
quit
so these these questions were completely
in the dark
as far as i know and no one seems to be
responsibly
investigating these questions despite
the large
number of citizens who take psychiatric
drugs
and the young people is very important
to the
again those all of those drugs have only
been studied
very short term in fact there's there's
very few trials in
in young people so we many drugs have
been used in young people that have
never been studied
so it's uh it's um
it's surprising that we would we do it
but
uh it is uh it does seem crazy but we it
is happening unfortunately
it definitely does seem crazy um when i
stopped
some of the symptoms i had were like
about about two weeks after i stopped
i hallucinated it which and i've looked
it up it's like what the hell was that
that didn't happen before i started
taking ssris
uh like what was that uh and there are
papers saying
you can have you know visual
disturbances after you stopped taking
ssris but it was a full-on hallucination
i was like that's what was that
and then i've just noticed over so i
stopped taking them when i was 23 and
i'm 29
and it's just my brain just keeps
functioning better
like the longer i am off of those it's
better and better
and i've had some psychometric testing
done and that's changed
in a positive manner so it's just it's
unbelievable that there's
that what you're saying should be done
hasn't been done already
um about about doctors prescribing these
medications
if you go and see your family physician
is he required
in some manner to offer you ssris or is
he allowed to say
you know maybe you should look at your
relationship that isn't working or the
fact that you don't have a job
or you know whatever else is going on or
is he required to
come up with some sort of pharmaceutical
as a problem solver um no
definitely doctors aren't required to to
do anything
and um yes they they do receive some
training that uh
you know social factors and uh
psychotherapy
are are are the first um
uh treatments but it's
i i think the problem is that it's too
easy to just write a prescription right
and so they
that's that's how people uh get into
this uh
quick fix situation and they often don't
even talk about
okay well how long are you going to take
this uh
etc and uh um
and they're not aware of the trials or
the evidence the evidence is so
weak for these drugs that if you really
if you really had your time to study
that
and know that you would you just would
not take them
they're just it's just they're weak this
evidence is so weak
it um it could be simply a placebo
effect that is occurring that has
allowed these drugs to get on the market
so
and then as i say it's only short-term
trials and we
and they don't know the long-term
effects so so it's um
it's just a crazy situation
there is also something about the
the way the drugs are
actually manufactured by the the the
formulations
and there's an idea that you're supposed
to take this
every day for an indefinite period
you know and that is um
that's actually something fairly new
when you think about it that
i'm just supposed to take this as long
as
this person tells me to take it and i
have to do it every day i
i'm not supposed to do it just once i'm
not supposed to
do it twice i'm not supposed to decide
is this working for me really i'm told
let's
start with three months or six weeks
and then come see me again and we'll
reevaluate so the idea really is
is this sort of indefinite maintenance
of the person
on this regimen uh
and again it's because that's what
the short answer is it creates the
market
the commercial market and it maintains
this commercial market
uh is this what the patient truly
needs to be on this for all these
periods
even though their problem may be very
episodic or it may have just
arrived two weeks ago because of a huge
complex loss or so that's just
recognized
all of this is not so explored mostly
it's
keep the person on and let the physician
decide um what what's to come next
so there's a kind of disempowering
of the patient and the patient's
role in deciding what's working for them
because from the start it's implied
you're supposed to be on this
indefinitely
yeah and and then people
doing that i mean um people do tend to
forget
to take their drug now and again right
and so
and and most of these drugs um when you
when they stop
for a day or two they get uncomfortable
withdrawal effects and that kind of
reminds them
that they needed it in the first place
but it's really they don't they're not
appreciating that it's really a
withdrawal effect and it's not
a a reminder that they need it
so it's uh it's um self-fulfilling
unfortunately but uh
it's a it's a we need a greater
understanding for sure
of what what's going on
yes so um i would recommend people see
this made
this movie medicating normal because i
think it's uh
it's excellent and it it certainly gives
you a sense of what
of the bad things that can occur uh in
terms of these uh
drugs so i think it's an excellent movie
yeah i'm i'm gonna have a link uh in
show notes
and on the youtube description for
people so that they can watch the film
and i would definitely also recommend
watching it because this is serious and
um like dr cohen said the number of
people on
psychiatric medications or who are going
to be offered psychiatric medications is
through the roof uh especially with
older people
um people like i know benzodiazepine use
is
really high amongst elderly women or in
native communities
and well people should know that in case
you get offered it or one of your family
members does or your kid
which is which is pretty scary
benzodiazepines are not usually offered
to kids
too much today but definitely older
people
are on them a lot a recent study from
france i just saw last week
showed that in this large sample of
french
older people
a good about a third of them were
taking benzodiazepines which is actually
relatively low
for france but 45
of those people on benzodiazepines were
judged
clinically dependent meaning they met
all of the current official criteria
for being dependent on benzodiazepines
which is a one of the highest rates i've
ever seen
in terms of dependence meaning they uh
apparently can't do without the drug
they're walking around with
you know uh uh doses in their purse
they're having withdrawal symptoms at
the at any you know
during the day they're thinking about
the drug constantly
at 40 percent of users that's huge
and the authors say uh that it it looks
quite reasonable to them
so the the problems could could be
extremely
high among older people
but geriatric medicine has
been one of the first ones to implement
deep prescribing
you know cleaning up people's medication
regimen
because so many older people are on so
many drugs
yeah very true yeah
okay um could you guys tell me what what
you think
the most well we just covered
benzodiazepines and i've been on enough
medication that i think
unfortunately and i think i could say
which ones
are most dependency forming but um could
you guys
give me kind of the you know the the
ones that
perhaps form dependencies the quickest
to the least quick
i know some of it's speculation but um
what do you guys think
well narcotics uh are quick
very quick and uh and benzodiazepines
are also very quick uh
it has been studied uh uh just even two
weeks of
uh of uh steady taking of a
benzodiazepine uh there is a
significant uh tolerance and and
withdrawal
and um and then but all of the
psychotropic drugs
i think we're learning uh do cause uh
tolerance
and and then and then potential um
withdrawal effects so that the
so the way to prevent that is not to
take anything on the long term
right so because your brain is going to
become tolerant to it
um it does occur even with
over-the-counter
antihistamines people can people develop
tolerance they they take those for sleep
and they get tolerant to it and then
it's actually not helping their sleep
but when they stop they get withdrawal
insomnia and
other side effects so so any drug that's
uh
affecting the brain uh causes tolerance
and uh
and and dependence and withdrawal i mean
and alcohol is another one right so if
you
if you're taking alcohol um and it's
affecting you throughout a 24-hour
period you're going to develop tolerance
and
and get into trouble again so yeah so
they're
it's uh it's it's something we've we've
learned and we we know but
we we continue then to come up with new
drugs that people
can be taking on the long term which is
uh which is the wrong
wrong way to go i think yeah
yeah that's really well said really well
stated dr wright
i think that uh the general rule might
be that anything that makes you feel
good physically and mentally together
is likely to have some um
withdrawal effect um
because uh almost by definition you know
if if if you feel good you want to do it
again
so and the more you do it the more
uh your body is setting up mechanisms
to counteract the presence of the drug
so the the longer you're taking the drug
the more your body is kind of
surrounding it and compensating for the
presence of drunk
and withdrawal is that when the drug
goes away
those compensatory mechanisms now have
free reign
so they're now going they're doing their
stuff
without the drug present and that's the
withdrawal symptoms
and so you don't want to take drugs too
long but the
coffee is definitely one of those
cigarettes as you know
we intuitively understand now
that after a a few takes of a cigarette
you're already setting up uh you know
dependency if you will you do it for
four or five six days in a row
you're going to feel withdraw instantly
as soon as you sort of within 10 minutes
so this people know and understand but
again they're told that these
prescribed drugs by definition approved
by the regulatory agencies
they're they're different really but all
they're doing
the same way in the brain they all
alter the usual neurotransmission that
goes on
they all interfere in one way or another
with the normal mechanisms and so
that's a problem just need much more
education
much more education on this things
things that can be taught when you're in
elementary school
this is not necessarily specialized
medical knowledge
this is stuff that people need to know
to take care of themselves
take care of their bodies this is like
drinking clean water
or breathing you know pure air it's
don't put into your body something that
is going to dramatically alter how your
brain is working
because it's going to backfire don't do
it for very long at all
do it in protected circumstances do it
because you really know
and they have been informed beforehand
do it because you trust the person
that's recommending that
don't just do it because everybody else
is doing
yeah very true yeah nicotine is a
highly addictive uh compound which
which we know but uh it's it's a good
example right so
we didn't originally know that right
like when it first came out it was
getting promoted by doctors and people
didn't know
uh so it started with that
yeah um so for for anybody listening who
is potentially freaking out because
they're on some sort of psychiatric
medication um
what do they do like don't just stop
like what are the safe steps to
figuring out how to remove it
well the first thing is to to to
come to appreciate that it's uh you know
that they want to get off
and um
and as a as we as i've said that we
don't have evidence that long-term use
is uh
is beneficial so uh they they should be
they should be motivated to
to not be taking medication yeah
and then they need to um
come up with a slow tapering program
and get some support and they hope
i mean mostly people who are all alone
have a hard time doing this so they
so somebody who can be there to support
them is
is helpful and then if they have a
physician who can help them to
make the decisions as to when to reduce
over time it's also helpful but but
people
are able to do it and there's lots of
good advice
on on the internet actually in terms of
people helping
and sometimes people get support from
somebody on the internet in terms of
of doing this but but the the key thing
is to
continue to reduce and when you're
having problems uh
you can maybe stay at that level for a
while
but then but never go back up and
always always reduce and then
take some you know take the positive in
the fact that you
you are taking less uh over time and
then i'll ultimately
get off and uh and if you continue to
have
withdrawal effects uh just depreciate
that those are withdrawal effects and
that they will dissipate over time and
so that's
that's the key i think i i would i
great great advice again i would add to
that
uh the notion that um you might not
want to have the goal to completely
stop and that just reducing your
exposure
is a big big accomplishment in itself
so that many people because of various
circumstances in their life
are just not in a position to
stop taking medications even if it takes
them a year
they're just too dependent on others
that have a say over their lives
so just reducing your exposure reducing
the dose because in north america we
have a tendency
to give higher drugs higher doses than
in many other countries for the same
drug
it's just this sort of cultural stance
maybe a little less in canada
but um so just
you know having ha uh diminishing by
half
over time not in one step but just
that is already a big accomplishment
you've reduced your exposure to
something that could
potentially be quite toxic to you by
half
that's really good maybe later you want
to reduce that again eventually by
another half
and that is also very good and so on
so that to me is very important plus
planning it
there are a few websites i would uh
single out
surviving antidepressants.org
i would single out the
withdrawalproject.org
they are two really really good
state-of-the-art
completely different one from the other
websites
lay lay withdrawal community of users
both of them
they're not run by professionals they're
run by ordinary lay
quote lay people um and they
have amazing advice much
better than anything that is currently
available
in any textbook of pharmacology or
psychopharmacology
yeah in terms of benzodiazepines uh the
the heather ashton manuel uh is also
available free on the on the internet uh
just uh um google
uh benzodiazepine withdrawal ashton uh
you'll you should you should come up
with it and and that
um was written some time ago but it
hasn't changed and uh and the
information in there is uh is is still
uh just as useful as ever so
it's very um almost all my patients
on benzodiazepines uh use that manual to
to help them
may i add one last thing on that on is
you need someone that that you can count
on
to to help you through this that makes a
big difference some person a friend
a counselor someone who trusts
in your ability to undergo that process
or if they don't completely trust you
that way
you trust them and and they'll give you
feedback
and they'll just support you that's
that's really important in my view
yeah i agree completely there are some
really good online communities for that
um i know specifically for
benzodiazepine use but for
for antidepressants as well that if you
are by yourself
you can definitely find somebody online
who's going through something similar
and you guys can help each other
that definitely exists online and it's
pretty easy to find when you go into
reddit or
some of these online communities and
i'll link some of them below in the show
notes too if
if people are interested
okay so how come i guess we can we can
kind of try and wrap up with this
because i don't think i have
the main message i wanted to get across
was that
these medications aren't safe for
long-term use
and that some of the things that you're
told
might be the re-emergence of symptoms uh
are most likely withdrawal um which
which looks different right like with
opiates it's
pretty obvious it's like sweating it can
be it can get really bad
you know nausea and some you know
depression
but and it can be terrible but with
antidepressant use it can look a little
bit different and
i don't think people necessarily
recognize that as not just another
psychiatric condition
so that's and and it's weird because
you think logically if you're talking to
somebody that if you take a drug
daily it's going to be dependence
forming
it seems obvious but then we're taught i
was taught
anyway from such a young age that you
know them
that these certain ones were not like
that
for some reason uh and i think a lot of
people still think that
and it's very dangerous so thank you
both for
talking about that but um i wanted to
finish off with just why did you guys
start
talking about this specific issue we
could start with we could start with dr
wright
um well it uh
uh in my in my career i've done a lot of
work in uh
in treating hypertension um and uh
and and learning the evidence for the
treatment of hypertension and there are
some situations where
long-term use of drugs is is important
in that
in that case but but over time
i had more and more patients who were
coming to me
with with significant problems and
symptoms and
and i was able to perceive that uh
often the drugs that they were taking
were the cause of their problems and so
i
i started to get uh um
uh comfortable with tapering
and and stopping drugs for people and
then it became known that i was doing
this and so then i've had more and more
people being referred to me
just for that for that use
um i also tape her antihypertensive
drugs
and successfully and so you know so it's
not it's not just uh
um these psychiatric uh drugs
yeah so it we we are taking too many
drugs in north america
and uh i've just come back from the
united states and been
exposed to all of the direct consumer
prescribing
information on on the tv and it's just
it's not surprising that so many people
are taking drugs because they're being
bombarded with this idea that drugs are
the solutions so
that's something that really needs to
change in the united states uh
that's that's totally inappropriate
having uh direct-to-consumer prescribing
or
their consumer ads for for for
prescription drugs but uh
yeah you can see where you know why we
have gotten into this problem it's uh
this
this idea that there's a quick fix right
so but that's how i
i got into it and and now
about half of my practice is uh helping
people to uh
come off of uh psychotropic drugs
actually
in my case i started doing this when
as a young professor of social work
at the university of montreal
i was asked to come and uh talk about
prescription drugs to some groups of
patients and a couple of the psychiatric
hospitals
that was back in the late 80s
and the first question people would ask
after i
gave my little talk was uh
how do i get off these things it's
impossible
it's so hard and so with a group of
ex patients and a couple of user groups
in quebec
in 1995 i co-wrote a
git critique of a book
a critical guide for
psychotropic drugs which was at the 1995
it was published
and uh with a grant from health and
welfare canada too
and it had uh one of the very first
books
that detailed anything we knew about
withdrawal reactions and how to come off
drugs
it was meant for users and um
it just didn't stop in other words the
request came about that
and a few years later peter bregen a
uh an american physician a psychiatrist
and i wrote a book called your drug may
be your problem
how and why to stop taking psychiatric
drugs
that was 1999 and that and then we just
systematically
reviewed all the literature which at the
time was just emerging on the internet
also
first-person reports the original
product
reports by ordinary citizens on their
medications
uncensored unfiltered by anything
and that was really mind opening and
that was done that was already over 20
years ago
and that's come out in another edition
in 2007 and so as a result
like dr wright people heard that i was
doing that and i'm not a medical doctor
i'm a clinical social worker i'm an
independent scientist and i'm a
professor
in a university and so i uh
people i would just talk to them on the
phone and i would counsel them on what
they could do
and it's uh it's just not stocked
for for the last uh 25 years
i have a many people successfully and
others
they were not able to come off their
drugs especially the benzodiazepines
i can't remember the statistic um but
there's some horribly high
number of people who are on
benzodiazepines never get off of them
they start and then they never stop i i
can't remember what it is but i think
it's over 50
it's it's not
and uh yeah people who have been
addicted
to opioids and and benzodiazepines
um will consistently tell you that it's
easier to stop opioids
or narcotics than it is benzodiazepines
benzodiazepines are much more difficult
to stop
so that's interesting in itself yeah
that's
that's very interesting because what we
like i said most people i think are
aware of the
opioid crisis and how addictive those
medications are
but benzodiazepines according to
forearms according to what i've seen
are a entirely different monster for
coming off
and and the symptoms aren't just aren't
just like physical
they're just it's everything right it's
it's horrifying
um i guess there's one more question i
forgot to ask that
that i want to ask um how much
do you so because my my dad was put on
benzodiazepines and had such
such horrible acatheia and and severe
withdrawal
i did a lot of research and
i've noticed that a lot of suicides
from famous people are from people
who've been medicated
so i'm wondering how much of the suicide
how
like what percentage of the suicides
we're seeing have something to do with
negative effects of psychiatric
medications
do you guys have any idea about any
statistics regarding that
i i don't think there are any clear
statistics on that
i think that you'll find that a number
of people who commit suicide
are have have troubles in life
and those people will have gone to see
doctors
and are likely to have been medicated
and diagnosed with various conditions
mental condition psychiatric conditions
it doesn't really mean that that is what
is causing the suicide
the suicide may be something entirely
different or separate from
all of that so we don't have clear
statistics
no one is responsibly gathering
statistics on that
so you do have um uh in the united
states you have when there is a suicide
at least 30 of the
or 40 of the states have a protocol in
place
where they do an entire sort of
investigation on the person including
you know the autopsy and and they do the
determinations of what's in the blood
and
and so forth and they report it and it
goes to some central database
uh and usually about at least a third or
or more of people are on some
cocktail of medications and
which includes often includes
antidepressants and other drugs
and other illicit drugs and
benzodiazepines
it's all mixed in there but there's no
clear attempt
to try to see what role the drugs may
have played
because retrospectively it's hard to
figure out
really hard but akathisia is itself
considered a a precipitant
of suicide because people just cannot
bear the discomfort they feel like they
want to jump
out of their skin and many many
first-person accounts say
they think the only thing that will stop
it is to kill themselves
not because they want to die because
they just cannot see another solution to
stopping that internal
agitation which is akathesia
it's not known to occur with the
benzodiazepines too much but with this
ssris yes and especially with the
antipsychotic drugs
yeah i agree uh completely with what uh
what you said
and we don't really have statistics but
we we certainly
know of anecdotes of people who have
committed suicide
due to uh going through withdrawal
etc and we do know that ssris and
antidepressants
increase the risk of suicidal ideation
and suicide so they
they don't they don't decrease suicide
and that's what you'd really be looking
for if you were looking for an effective
treatment for a severely depressed
person is
you'd want something that that decreased
their chance of suicide and actually
it's they increase the chance of suicide
not decrease it so
so it's uh we don't you know that's
that's that's another reason
that these are not drugs to be
prescribed and
in for that condition so it's um
that's why it's surprising so many
people are taking them
the point that doctor i just made now
about the increase of suicide of the
ssris you have to remember
that that that's precisely that's a very
strong finding
from these admittedly imperfect
short-term trials
that is in these admittedly imperfect
short-term randomized controlled trials
you have a doubling a doubling of the
suicide risk
from about you know one percent in the
placebo group
to double that in the medicated group
and so that that's a huge finding
from these short term six week to eight
week trials
and that finding the authorities who
prescribed and promote the drugs do
everything to say that's really just a
noise that's not really
true whereas the therapeutic effects
are the the difference between the
placebo
and the control is much smaller than
that it's not
double the the therapeutic effect on
drugs and on placebo
it's an extra couple of percent more
it's almost the same
whereas the suicide risk is twice
the difference it's just a really
important point
to keep in mind
yeah um one of the scary things i read
specifically about akathisia because i
know that
the suicide risk among people who
experience academia is insanely high
because it's so intolerable
and i've seen what it looks like in
person and it is not pretty
but one of the things that you'll read
in the list of side effects is you'll
read a number of different words that
avoid using the word akathesia
so you'll see agitation or restlessness
which are like toned down words for
physically wanting to jump out of your
skin right
so that's another sneaky thing that's
been done with some of these side
effects and it's like
drowsiness restlessness and people like
i can deal with a little bit of
restlessness but
sometimes it doesn't look like sometimes
that's the wrong word to be using to
describe some of these side effects or
withdrawal symptoms
well they're not really side effects by
the way they're direct
yeah the drug they may not be intended
but they are what happens and they might
occur
more frequently than the intended
effects so
just by calling them side effects i just
wanted to bring attention to that that
our language
itself minimizes their occurrence they
may be more
frequent even though their side
yes that's a very good point i read that
with
antipsychotic medications these
akathisia feeling can
can be a 30 percent of people which is
insane given how suicidal acathesia
patients are
like it it just boggles my mind
yes akathesia can can uh take on a
delayed form it's called tardive
academia
and um you know in in many papers from
several years ago already two three four
decades
cardiff akathesia is described as a
permanent problem with you know many
cases described with
no resolution years after people had
ceased taking the drugs
so i hope it's rare but uh
it doesn't seem that it's that rare
when i was doing research so i i did a
lot of research on academia
because my dad kept going to doctors and
the doctors didn't recognize that it was
akathesia they thought it was some
underlying problem and kept
medicating it which made the academia
worse so i did a lot of research on
academia and
from all the case reports of academia
that i read
for tardive academia i couldn't find a
case report of someone who'd come off of
every single medication a lot of those
case reports they were still on
one stabilizing medication and maybe it
wasn't an antipsychotic maybe it was a
sleeping pill
or maybe it was something else but i
couldn't find anybody
who had been unsuccessful treating their
tardive acatheia if they'd
spent an extended amount of time off of
everything
so that might give people if they're
experiencing it some hope because i
really couldn't find one study where it
was
someone who'd gone completely clean for
at least you know a month and a half or
two months
that hadn't been able to get rid of it
good point yeah so it's worth and i
think i think the brain has an
incredible
capacity to heal if you let it heal and
you stop irritating it
um so i completely believe people can do
it
um and some people it might take longer
some of the things i found
incredibly helpful weirdly enough was an
infrared sauna in the morning
and sweating and it seemed my withdrawal
symptoms were
significantly worse in the morning and
that made a
huge difference so that um
removing some of the more inflammatory
foods i was eating like grains
uh i made a huge difference and uh
exercise made a bit of a difference but
not it wasn't
it wasn't insane but um sauna's
sweating and uh cleaning up my diet made
a huge difference
for withdrawal for people listening so
there are things you can do
but getting some support is is a good
start
yep healthy lifestyle all those things
and
and the idea that uh healing can occur
i think that's that's really important
for people to to appreciate him so
that's what a lot of
uh of the the websites you might be
linking people to and so they have many
personal histories
uh of of how people completely
emancipated themselves physically and
mentally from the drugs
and uh and and completely recovered and
and went on to
to accomplish good things that they
wanted to do so there are many of these
stories they're not necessarily all
published in journals and
you know with with dates and uh and
times and doses
but they they're very eloquent and
inspiring
for uh i think for anyone
is there anything else you guys want to
add before we
end the podcast
i'd love to say that all the drugs go
through some kind of
period of approval and rejection in
society these psychoactive drugs they go
through some kind of trajectory you know
like that you throw them into space and
then they
they get accepted then they get rejected
then there's a bit more balanced
assessment of what to do with them
and that's what happens to all of them
or in cycles like the benzodiazepines
they were great and they were not so
good now they're not so good but they're
also reviving in many other ways and
people promote them very heavily
and so it's like these are cycles and
the psychedelics are coming in as
treatments now they're being evaluated
in clinical trials
and there's something good about them
and there's also something that we don't
understand so well about them being used
on a mass scale
so all the people have to know that
there's no simple answer out there
that's going to tell you what to do
a lot of it falls on you as an
individual to really
exercise your critical judgment and
and uh and seek not only just
like-minded people but also
people who think differently and get
different perspectives on things
and uh before you make up your mind so
you know be it's it's a long wild ride
that we're in
it's not gonna stop so get ready for the
journey
yeah and the new the newer the drugs the
less we know
about it and so so it's not like uh you
want to get the newest
and thing in this case particularly
so a really new drug is something that
we know very little about
and so yeah i would be very cautious
about anything any taking
anything that's new
okay dr cohen dr wright thank you so
much for joining me
i hope people find this useful and i
will link everything
in show notes and in the description
including a link
to medicating normal which people should
watch
so thank you yeah it's been my pleasure
and uh
i enjoyed uh sharing this with you dr
cohen yeah
aim here same here thank you very much i
learned a lot
thanks for having us
[Music]
you